elle attend
mais si me collard et
le live en soi
nicolas vous avez presque 30 ans nicolas
vous êtes journaliste au figaro et azur
balle chroniqueur à la télévision sur
france 3 dans une émission de franz
olivier giesbert qui s'appelle culture
et dépendances
il est sympa giesbert ça va ça se passe
bien mais est ce qu'il lit les livres
parce qu'il va venir la semaine
prochaine et je vais demander un truc
parce qu'il a quand même un truc
giesbert extraordinaire il prend un
bouquin par exemple dans son émission
alors il est comme ça il dit nicolas rey
bonsoir vous publiez 13 minutes alors
c'est l'histoire d'un mec là est ce que
c'est un genre qui se donne ou non c'est
pas le cas je crois vraiment qu'il y
lire
alors vous êtes aussi et surtout je
dirais écrivain vous avez publié trois
livres et nous les pitchs et le produit
s'appelle 13 minutes
j'ai eu en fait ce qui s'appelle un
chagrin d'amour
une fille au bout de au bout de trois
mois m'a dit d'un air désolé déjà je me
suis rendue compte qu'elle m'aimait plus
parce qu'en fait elle elle j'avais ma
main dans la dans la sienne
elle répondait plus aux pressions que
j'exerçais sur sam en fait elle était
décédée
qu'elle ait pu lui parler regarder le
foot est une fille avant sa voix
caressante pierre est je crois que c'est
encore pire choix qu'elle était
indifférente et et donc elles
répondaient plus du tout est en fait
dans ces cas là on est un peu spectateur
de soi même à savoir qu' on se dit il
faut se casser c'est fini en aucun cas
elle elle va retomber amoureuse de toi
quand on aime plus on aime plus c'est
fini il faut s'en aller et puis pourtant
je ne sais pas par quelle mauvaise manie
on reste jusqu'à la lie on reste jusqu'à
la fin dans ces cas là je sais je sais
je sais pas à quoi c'est dû donc gt gt
gt dans ce dans ce café avec cette fille
est et est au bout de nos bouts de au
bout d'une heure elle m'a dit d'un air
désolé qu'elle n'était plus amoureuse de
moi
donc j'étais bien placé pour savoir
qu'en aucun cas çà çà çà pouvait ça
pouvait se reconquérir
quoique entreprennent à ce moment là ça
allait être considérée par elle comme de
l'acharnement ou téléphoniques ou
épistolaire si je peux minutes parce que
le pitch dure 13 minutes et et et c'est
important
3 en moins bien coiffé on les crée le
premier alors qu'ils n'ont mais c'était
important de bien servir une certaine
lenteur dans ce genre d'émission en tout
doit être rapide à l'heure et on n'a pas
le droit à l'erreur donc donc j'essaye
tant bien que mal de le faire et est
donc en fait je me suis je suis partie
de ce bistrot et j'ai écrit le livre de
ceux de cet ado les vagues et qui vit ce
chagrin d'amour et qui s'appelle très
bien qu'elle ait craint 13 minutes ça
c'est le premier le deuxième s'appelait
mémoire courte
oui le coach est rapidement lui sorti
c'est un titre un type qui se réveille
le le matin de son mariage il ya une
trentaine d'années et qui réalise que un
peu tardivement que les 30 années à
venir vont pas être forcément les plus
agréables à vivre
il décide de vivre vous avoue richard le
pari services a progressé pour inverser
si ça vous va bien savourer à de vifs
richard aux yeux de mon reprend fait
mais je n'en vois qu'un seul coup vous
êtes un père un petit peu autoritaire
comme ça alors que nous en arrivons au
début prometteur donc là qui a été salué
par une critique unanime je dois le dire
c'est vrai c'est pas pour lui il
s'appelle un début prometteur
tout le monde a dit oui voilà s'espacent
à vernon c'est les deux premiers c'était
des adultes qui essayait de retourner
vers l'adolescence et le et et le
troisième c'est un adolescent qui a
envie de vieillir c'est l'histoire
d'henri qu'à 15 ans et qui s'ennuient à
mourir à vernon à une heure de paris est
qui et qui passe ses journées comme
souvent c'est un peu la prison quand on
est comme ça
jeune lycéen à savoir le matin un cours
de sciences naturelles à 8h30 quoi qu'il
arrive à 13 heures des tonnes de
carottes râpées au réfectoire
donc la meilleure façon dans ces cas là
de deux de tenir le coup et de pouvoir
s'inventer une drogue non seulement en
vente libre et gratuite c'est le
sentiment amoureux donc qu'il tombe
amoureux de sa prof de français ce qui
lui permet un peu de mettre quelque
chose entre lui et le monde est d'avoir
un peu comme ça d'ivresse et des de
plaisir à vivre
voilà ce qui s'appelle un début
prometteur la critique comme je les dis
extrêmement élogieuse à on a parlé de
fitzgerald salinger de bukowski et en
france 2 de philippe joe raedle de
besson bah oui c'est vrai tout le monde
était extrêmement sûre et les olives
bacalan lait du mois tout le monde a été
surpris par la disparition de votre côté
m'as tu vu on a dit que j'ai tjrs et des
mondes anisé on a dû ces puits en rade
cocktail c'est puis un courtisan
c'est un vrai écrivain ça vous a fait
plaisir ça n'a pas l'air non mais pas
plus que ça je pensais pas avant être
forcément un rat de cocktails et
l'infini estime et j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup d'amitié sans vraiment
connaître nicolas mais je les croisais
une fois quelques instants qui voit mort
non on en a les taximen non non pas du
tout alors j apprécie cet instant là
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de temps dans
des saunas c'est toujours sympa on fait
bien rire les trois bouquins dont il
vient de parler sorte au diable vauvert
dans un petit coffret
voilà les trois ligues de nicholas ray
donc sorte au diable vauvert ans la
dernière fois qu'il est venu c'était
pour la journée de la femme ou souvenait
très bien j'ai beaucoup parlé de sodomie
plutôt que de vos bouquins ce soir là et
vous disiez ou aux femmes de s'équiper
de bottes ceinture pour montrer aux
makes que ça faisait vous souvenez de ça
et je vous ai trouvé ce soir là très
proche